[Laughter]
do you identify as black
no it's a serious question because you
might not identify
can you please put the mic thank you do
you identify as black
oh my god
oh
i gotta play that [ __ ] back hold on hold
on
we gotta we gotta bring it back oh my
god we gotta bring up listen somebody
sent me this and i needed
god
hold on i gotta play back i gotta play
that let me play that not ready i'm not
ready shout out to playback oh my god
ready yeah do you identify as black
[Laughter]
oh
please help me jesus
jazzy listen
you're talking to me no matter how
whitewashed you think this man is you
know matter no matter how whitewashed
you think this man is
oh my god i'm looking at his face his
gray hair is demeanor
this [ __ ] comes from an era
where you were black or not
there's no identification of
naguana here there was no such thing
poop pop out the belly of your mommy
you're black or white it's black
it's white
yeah yeah yeah that's what it was you
understand what the [ __ ] i'm saying
classic
classic yes but even in africa yeah i
quite enjoyed this one
this one is
it's like this young bra is gonna come
up to me with yeah with your privilege
that you have with your lighter skin
tone that you have
there's a lot there's a lot of death and
there's a lot of layers all right but
whatever honor that's why i understood
the laugh where the laugh is from i
don't know what the situation here but
that's what i can read all right i'm
done you can proceed to give the people
what they need rob
i wouldn't even expect a schizophrenic
homeless person to ask me this question
do you know how [ __ ] unhidged you
have to sound to shock even clayton
bigsby
it is his sickness and it is deviant do
you identify as black
no it's a serious question because you
might not identify
can you please put the mic thank you
okay uh when i walked into it
i am
[Music]
hey
oh
my god now this is what you call
triggered
oh my god okay
okay
okay
okay
that's what it's going to be huh
okay
okay that's that's that's what we choose
to do today huh
huh
okay i do good
i'm super good let's go you sure i'm
good cuz she interrupted him how do you
feel no no no this she asked him a
question she interrupted how you feel
tell us the truth how you feeling there
tell us this how this tell us
we all want to know
this what we doing today we try to
interrupt [ __ ] when we ask the
question is that what we're trying to do
today huh you asked the question huh
huh
is that
you ask the question
and then i try to add the answer to the
question that you ask
because you asked it
and then
you interrupt me into saying that you
were not done
is you is you is you mad
or is you crazy
i think it's both of them
b-o-f-f-u-m
b-o-f-f-u-n both phone
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
what happened whoo i gotta speak to my
ancestors and call my spirits
ah
this could be a tough one
this is
ah [ __ ] is gonna be a tough one oh
oh there's gonna be a tough one no
matter
oh [ __ ] right i you know
whoa okay
[Laughter]
okay
okay i really suspect that i deserve a
raise for triggering preach
okay
if you guys enjoy these triggering
moments
let me know if i deserve a ring you you
should shut the [ __ ] up and play the
video breath
you proud of yourself
oh this one's a ah this one's going to
be a rough one if i'm being serious
go up to an old black man at this point
i'm just being honest to go up to an old
black man with gray hair and ask him
do you identify as black like
the levels are [ __ ] unhinged and
disconnected you have to be from reality
to say some [ __ ] like that is crazy to
me even your own parents will be like
should i not raise you better than this
there you go who raised you oh [ __ ] it's
me
how did we [ __ ] this up
there you go two black men talking down
don't even speak english she saw this
clip she slapped the [ __ ] out of me
i'm tim minhonk
well deserved well deserved that is
crazy
that is crazy now as far as as far as
her
feeling some type of way and being hyper
emotionally angry that i could
understand if she feels like his
policies are so oppressive and going to
hurt people and marginalized people that
she needs to go out and regret i can
understand that and i'll grant you that
space
asking him do you identify as black
that's crazy this is so absurd but you
know from her perspective she probably
thinks she's being compassionate because
she's been taught and indoctrinating
this whole idea that she's supposed to
ask everyone what do you identify as but
for people who've had to live with the
reality that was not the point of her
question what you mean that was not a
point of a question she was not asking
to ask she was asking to prove a point
that what you're saying you're not even
black because if
if it was if it was compassion if it was
compassion when it's compassionate i'm
supposed to listen to your [ __ ]
answer okay that was not a compassionate
thing where she was like what so what do
you think okay cool just want to make
sure that was not that no are you even
black is the undertone of a shimini
shaya
shanda what the [ __ ] she was saying
that's what it was okay that was not
that was a jab that was a
that was a that was trying to
hurt a person okay that was trying to
take away the blackness of a person i
was trying to weaponize weaponize the
fact that you're doing your policies and
if you're doing those policies you must
not be black that was there was zero
compassion in what it was and what it is
none stop hey i didn't even see it from
that perspective i'm gonna tell you like
that
i ain't mad at you now that you say it
like that it does sound more plausible
because it's not gonna lie once you laid
it out like that i was like
this is triggered no but he right no
just cause he triggered don't mean he
can't be right that is that there was
zero compassion in this [ __ ] that was
not the point of that are you black
because if you were really black you
would understand me right there that's
what it was
that's a crazy question it's funny how
[ __ ] always
it's funny
how the most as the sjw [ __ ]
especially from the black community
talking about immune community uh we
have to be e-wiped at night we after
that they're the first one to separate
you oh you're not black they're gonna
dictate how to should hack as a black
person what music you should listen to
as a black person who the you should
date as a black person or else you're
not black we're unity but you're out of
there because you're not thinking like
me it's funny y'all it's always those
same [ __ ] when you call them
out you're like ah how dare you how dare
you talk say the most outlandish and
stupid [ __ ]
they go out and say the most outlandish
[ __ ] and call you all type of name
traitor the minute you call them out oh
my god i can't just think like that
shut the [ __ ] up
shut up it's always you [ __ ]
that do that always the most profiting
black but you're the ones that [ __ ] on
us the first one the minute we don't
agree with you you're like oh my god
you must not be shut the [ __ ] up
that's what it is it's always those one
it's [ __ ] up that in my life it's
[ __ ] up that in my life the
[ __ ] that boo the people that
believe me the most
more than white people is black woman
the people that come here get more it's
black woman yeah then there's black men
but you women the minute you don't want
them oh you must be at
the minute
the [ __ ] minute and then they say
they're pro black uh you have to respect
women man shut the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ]
up
and then you're gonna go up to a black
man a black and no black man that did
whatever he dealt with whatever the [ __ ]
he dealt with
he can't she can't even comprehend just
to have the audacity
and the privilege to walk up that
motherf in the microphone and be like
are you even
[ __ ] if you don't get the [ __ ] out of
my face
[ __ ] out of my face
talking about pro black knobby oh my god
preachers triggered [ __ ] yeah i am that
[ __ ] right there yeah it will get to me
yeah absolutely absolutely
congratulations i'm not even gonna lie
we can't even get to the policy issues
because uh
that question is a whole thing to unpack
and um
yeah if you're a young person watching
this don't be asking that question like
that especially the people who probably
don't buy into the kind of stuff that
you do because it can be very insulting
it was [ __ ] up how to walk thing like
i was woke for six months i was like
yeah [ __ ] this whole moment and then
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with y'all
god damn like if you're black [ __ ]
you got you got to go see a shrink okay
you went to too much trauma to not go
see a drink and then you're outside out
there with your problems and [ __ ] like
said go see
a shrink i'm seeing one
but all those [ __ ] all those trucks we
need to and then after that don't
[ __ ] bestow that unto other people
[ __ ]
all right well i think uh we started off
on a jesus [ __ ] [ __ ]